I am Michael Walzer and I'm a professor
emeritus at the Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton
I'm also the co-editor of dissent
magazine maher was born in the Bronx in
1935 and I spent my first nine years
there and then my parents moved to
Johnstown Pennsylvania which is a small
steel town east of Pittsburgh a little
Pittsburgh they moved there in 44 which
was just when the steel workers had
succeeded in organizing Johnstown was a
Union town and a democratic stronghold I
grew up there left Johnstown when I was
17 to go to Brandeis University in
Waltham Massachusetts after Brandeis I
do you want me to continue it
I had a Fulbright scholarship that took
me to Cambridge England for a year and
56 57 and then I went to Harvard
as a graduate student in the government
department and taught for one year at
Harvard after I got my PhD and then for
four years at Princeton and then came
back to Harvard in 1966 and I talked
there in the government department until
1980 and then I moved to the Institute
for Advanced Study and where I've been
ever since well I grew up in a leftie
household my parents were readers of a
newspaper called p.m. which was a kind
of Popular Front daily in New York
I have stone and max Lerner wrote for
4:00 p.m. we subscribed to if' stones
weekly even after we moved to the
Johnstown
so my parents were an important
influence and then at Brandeis I I met
Irving how and Lou Kosar the people who
were just setting up descent magazine
who were ex Trotskyists who had moved to
some kind of social democratic political
position and they were my my political
Mentors
I I grew up with politics politics was
the daily conversation I grew up during
World War two
which was also a very important factor
and then I came of age politically I
suppose just at the time when America
was opening up politically the civil
rights movement the anti-war movement
these were these were my training
grounds for for political political life
and Brandeis was a was a place where the
60s began in the 50s I was there from 52
to 56 and and it was already a hotbed of
the kind of politics that the rest of
the country experienced after 1960 well
the Montgomery bus boycott I think that
was 1954 and that Brandeis which was
very far away and where there were
practically no black students but there
were a lot of Jewish or red diaper
babies and Jewish lefties of different
sorts the the that was that was for us a
very crucial event and we organized just
rallies in in support of the of the
Montgomery of the Montgomery bus boycott
so that was that was an important
feature in the and then there was the
Rosenberg
the which was very important at a Jewish
especially important at a Jewish
University and we divided some of us
thought that they were probably guilty
and and we were maybe the the children
of of socialists rather than of
Communists and others thought that
Brandeis was a place where the debates
between Stalin and Trotsky went on long
after they had they had ceased in the
rest of the in the rest of the world so
no I read the first issues of dissent
magazine
I went canvassing for Adlai Stevenson so
it was a it was an open politics we
weren't left sectarians at all
canvassing for Adlai Stevenson a Jewish
kid in Waltham Massachusetts we probably
did him more harm than than good but we
were very earnest and and committed to
the political action and it was in the
course of my political activities of
traveling south in 1960 and of
organizing Vietnam summer in 67 it was
in the course of those activities that I
began to realize that I was I was using
up a political language that I that I
didn't understand very well and that
that deserved some reflection and and
articulation more more more theoretical
articulation and that's when I began to
think about myself as possibly a
political theorist
well I would want to strengthen the
protection that poor people get in the
legal system strengthen of the public
defender system and and strengthen the
just the the ability of ordinary people
to to function in a legal system which
which is often difficult to maneuver if
you don't have expert help